[Music]  that's what girl Mila Kunis and Ashton  Kutcher made a surprise appearance on  Monday night's Bachelorette Monday nets  fries are a white wine white wine vodka  tonic yep travel back all right  the actors are big bachelor nation fans  this right here wife material is amazing  to have Mila and Ashton to help figure  out who's husband material for me and  helped with a challenge to find someone  who can do husband tests at home I'm  definitely gonna win this racial oh god  there's so much poop  [Music]  I'm husband material yeah whoa Ashton  had a harsh early prediction  I don't think Rachel's guy is in this  group but a much sweeter comment for his  wife you're rushing from space I'll take  him slow we only have six weeks I knew  one day one that was definitely getting  laid tonight  [Music]